juste que c'était ce qu'on va voir et je
suis stressé aussi de a dit qu'on va
faire parce que c'est pas c'est pas
anodin quand même parce qu'on va faire
ce soir salut à tous et morgan intel
gipsy je suis avec charlie danger et
aujourd'hui on va s'infiltrer dans un
élevage de porcs intensifs en bretagne
on va essayer d'observer un peu les
conditions de vie de ces animaux et
comment est-ce qu'ils sont traités par
ces émissions du jour
[Musique]
et honnêtement je suis pas stressé
anxieuse et will i am il est pas stressé
il faut tout regarder tu vois tu veux
regarder où est ce que sont les cochons
morts machin
il faut chercher
ça prend du temps je pourrai s'arrête
dans ma chambre dans
parce qu'il faut le faire comme il faut
ils se plaisent en voix
vidéo puisque
je ressens pas au courant ils pensent
que
les cochons ils sont arrivés en planeur
dispose même pas de question et il
s'imagine même pas je pense que c'est la
bonne dessin et que cuba après on
remonte un petit peu c'est là bas à
droite
c'est une voiture qui passe dans le
champ nom changement
là il est minuit et william là il nous
emmène dans le premier
juste derrière toi là vous c'est
normalement une salle d'engraissage
[Musique]
allez première salle c'était cojean de
tous les côtés par des cochons
présentation et d'héroïsme une apogée
avec
[Musique]
déjà là je me sens 1 2
et tout fait quoi tu vois ce genre tu te
sentais même pas l'espèce veut parcourir
dit m elles sont que face au mur il ya
une petite fenêtre qui qui met un petit
peu de lumière intérieure petites traces
de griffures c'est parce qu'ils
bâtissent agressent contre la naissance
ils ont les dents coupée pour éviter de
justement d'avoir à se mordre de se
blesser en se mordant et on voit qu'ils
ont toutes des petites que parce que tu
coupes et en fait c'est parce qu'il sait
les flamands gens entre eux ils ont rien
à faire ils ont envie de mortiers des
trucs qu'ils ont envie de mâcher des
trucs qui bouscule sans arrêt en
permanence se sont pressés de rentrer au
canada donc qu'ils vous laissent comme
ça c'est vraiment rude et là ce qui les
rend la vie à dos et son chapeau mais ça
sent vraiment mauvais c'est super chaud
et j'imagine même pas l'aider
comment comment ça doit être et c'est
pourquoi toute la terre qu'ils ont sur
autres c'est pas de la trc des
excréments et c'est pas seulement sur
les faits c'est sur le museau c'est
partout
là c'est tout les excréments et là
laurine qui est on ils ont ce système de
sol à jour est comme ça ils n'ont pas
besoin de sortir les cochons d box les
cochons peuvent rester ici plusieurs
semaines mais il ya quand même plein
excréments qui reste donc qu à chaque
fois qu'ils se couchent ce qui dans
leurs excréments
c'est légal genre sa s'est autorisée
c'est normal
[Musique]
et
le but c'est de faire
le plus de profit possible d'avoir des
cochons qui vont grossir le plus vite
possible à moindre coût en dépensant le
moins d'énergie le moins de travail le
moins de main d'oeuvre le moins de
nourriture tout le but c'est la
rentabilité c'est pas du tout le bien
être animal ça c'est sûr il ya de la
nourriture qui distribue automatiquement
dans leur gamelle une espèce de bruit
c'est de l'eau mélangée à du décès réel
lassé vivent encore tout ce qu'ils font
c'est manger dormir et chier et c'est
tout on tourne en rond
tu vois ça a besoin à tout juste 2 100es
la nourriture mais si en train de vous
dans notre île et réveille la nuit juste
pour les nourrir ce qui se passe parce
que la ci dormait la nourriture et
serait tombé en plus ils attendaient la
nourriture dont 10 réveille tôt
je
[Musique]
voir de visu comme ça ce qui finalement
va se retrouver dans nos assiettes
là je prends vraiment conscience de des
conditions de vie qui se marchent
les uns sur les autres j'arrive pas à
croire que ce soit l'homme qui pète ça
je me sent très coupable c'est pour
semer de la viande pendant une grosse
partie de ma vie et ma prise de
conscience le jeune ariane elles sont
relativement tardivement et quand je
vois ça je me dis juste que j'ai autant
de consommateurs
quand on achète une barquette de gens de
bon on n'a pas en tête ce qui est en
train de se passer actuellement on sait
juste assez du jambon ont cédé jolie
tranche tout rose ça me fait du bien ça
va être très bien mon prof monsieur
fillon n'a pas forcément en tête
l'impact que cela peut avoir sur les
animaux
il est en train de crever celui-là
ça fait peut-être de trois heures qui se
fait piétiner
voilà
j'entends beaucoup de personnes en eau
entourage me dire à moi toutes ces
images là je ne surtout pas les voir
sinon ça va me dégoûter et justement si
vous savez que ça va vous dégoûter c'est
qu'il ya une raison
donc à partir de là il faut il faut se
demander pourquoi est ce qu'on a
vraiment d'être cautionner ça est ce
qu'on a envie d'être une civilisation
qui cautionnent ce genre de choses qui
le fait moi en tout cas ça me fait
réfléchir et je me pose sincèrement la
question
[Musique]
où
si on arrivait dans le bâtiment des
maternités la porcelaine mais ce dont il
garde les truies dans des cages fermées
vous allez voir c'est juste ici
il ya un bébé mort le gars juste l'année
en cours
là d'un
db
qui en train de mourir juste là ils
merck et entre
qui s'éteint est ce que votre suite sans
payer
oui
le regard même leur regard sur roya la
détresse mais y'a tellement d'effet
c'est là je pense que
pierre au début
[Musique]
et comme elles l ont aucun espace pour
vivre voilà on a l'exemple type
penser
15 h à passy h & m je bous et puis voilà
c'est ça être allongée pour pouvoir
aller des jeux tout ce qu'elle peut
faire bas je peux pas comprendre tous
mangé ses jambes derrière c'est pas
possible tout le monde devrait être
confronté à cette réalité là il se rend
compte de nos actes et de la manière
dont on consomme tous les jours parce
que c'est ce qu'on est en train de boire
c'est notre faute en fait on restait
vingt jours d'arrêt qui sont sevrés au
bout de vingt jours alors que vraiment
les animaux il se serait
dans les industries vivons les séparés
de leur mère au bout de vingt jours et
dans les cinq premiers jours ils doivent
les castrais qui vont arracher adif
testicules ou avec des pinces coupantes
et les petits ils vont dans les stalles
qu'on a vu qu'ils sont dépassés dans
d'autres salles et puis après quand ils
grossissent un peu trop dans notre salle
encore et au fur et à mesure
[Musique]
voici tous les petits qui ont pas
survécu
on
les foetus et les petits qui eux
tous ceux qui sont mort nés les truies
sont sélectionné génétiquement pour
faire déporter de plus en plus
nombreuses elles peuvent faire déporter
de douze treize quatorze petits
porcelets
tous ne survivent pas
les certains vont mourir aussi dans les
premières heures ont les premiers jours
de leur naissance
et pas un élevage sais j'ai un film
d'horreur ce qui choque le plus ce qu'on
rentre dans ses cellules assez
l'ambiance que soit l'ambiance olfactive
parce que c'est une odeur quai qui est
vraiment très très dur je pense que la
nouvellement voir trappe rayé pense que
là c'est le lendemain et on allait les
tous les vêtements là c'est l'horreur
quand tu es sur place tu te rends compte
de vraiment à quel point on s'en fout de
ces animaux quoi tu vas y en avait qui
étaient éparpillés un peu partout par
terre qui était mort on a vraiment
entendu armement des décrypte l de
souffrance a écrit d'ehlers dirait une
salle de torture ou pas vraiment
vraiment mal de sortir car non en fait
si on change pas notre manière de
consommer la viande ça changera jamais
ce qu'on a vu hier il faudrait une sorte
de prise de conscience collective ou
alors trouver ces lieux au public pour
que tout le monde puisse s'y rendre et
qu'on s'était par soi même et après
prendre la décision de consommer de la
viande mais que ce soit un choix entre
guillemets sens et ce soit en ayant
toutes les cartes en main pour
comprendre ce que ça implique
après la soirée d'hier dans un élevage
intensif de plus de deux mille cochons
on a décidé de partir dans les landes
chez un éleveur qui en élève juste 4 et
qui va nous expliquer comment il fait et
les solutions pour pouvoir en arriver là
et pouvoir
lv déco font de manière éthique
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
si on est à cames dlan la forme
fantastique c'est une petite ferme qu'on
a créé avec ma compagne trois ans on est
à la fois éleveurs donc de porc gascon
le brebis landaises de chèvres des
pyrénées de poules gasconnes on a deux
canards les ports gascon ils vont avoir
finalement une vie qui va s on va tenter
en tout cas de la rapprocher le plus
possible de ce qu'ils auraient connu
dans un milieu naturel et vont trouver
en fait en permanence sur le sol tout un
tas de d'aliments ça va être de l'air
bien sûr qu'ils représentent une grande
partie leur alimentation ça va être des
verts parce qu'il ya beaucoup de berre
dans le sol c'est un sol vivant ça va
être des l'art ça va être ça va être des
racines ça va être voilà tout un tas de
choses on va quand même les nourrir un
petit peu il y aura un complément s'est
passé pas grand chose c'est des restes
de végétaux c'est des restes de légumes
de la ferme c'est les patates qui ont
germé de l'année dernière qu'on va cuire
c'est de l'ortie aussi des anciens qui
vont lice à une poignée d'ortie par jour
et les cochons grand jamais le
vétérinaire et je sais pas si c'est vrai
mais ils n'ont jamais vu le vétérinaire
en tout cas on n'a jamais eu de pépin
sur la forme ils ont besoin de faire
quoi ces animaux pour leur bien-être
c'est courir
manger équilibré c'est une bonne
sociabilisation c'est ne pas être
stressé dans son environnement c'est
tout un tas de choses finalement donc
nous mêmes en nous avons besoin pour
pouvoir là pour notre développement
personnel tous les jours on travaille
énormément je le cache pas c'est
beaucoup de boulot mais on y prend
beaucoup de plaisir c'est gratifiant les
gens reviennent vers nous les gens nous
reparle nous disent qu ils ont retrouvé
un goût dans l'oreillette dans notre
jambon qu'il n'avait pas trouvé depuis
un moment parce que ce cochon il ya du
goût parce que ce cochon il n'a pas été
élevé à l'eau et aux antibiotiques donc
forcément ça ça développe des arômes
différents
alors là on va aller préparer le sol
nourriture pour le soir on fait ça matin
et soir
c'est une mixture de tout un tas
d'aliments qu'on récupère soit sur la
ferme deyres le culture ça change tous
les jours en fonction de ce qu'on a
alors vous allez voir ça c'est le
meilleur moment de la journée et le
savent que c'est l'heure enfin vous le
savez et voilà les animaux ils me
rendent bien les animaux sont en pleine
forme les animaux sont moins stressés
moins malade voire pas du tout malade
choisi d'être un éleveur respectueux et
de faire les choses le mieux possible
on a fait beaucoup par nous mêmes c'est
la débrouille c'est les réseaux locaux
voilà on en est là ça fait trois ans là
non on vient de faire notre bilan c'est
plutôt bon on est dans le vert ça fait
vraiment plaisir
mais dans la dans l'élevage industriel
je pense que les investissements sont
gigantesques les machines sont énormes
ça coûte des centaines de milliers
d'euros alors même si certaines sont
subventionnés ça leur prend des fois 15
ans 20 ans finalement ils finissent par
vivre endettés ce qui les mène à
travailler comme ça finalement c'est
cesser cette espèce d'emballement depuis
les années 30 pour une une production
très intensive très spécialisés nous les
règles du jeu on a décidé de les écrire
nous même et encore des paysans de boue
qui ont connu les techniques paysanne
anciennes et qui les pratiquent encore
aujourd'hui le lien il pas encore
complètement brisé je pense qu'on peut
encore rétablir les choses
est ce qu'il faudrait aussi que le
français et 10 sa consommation de viande
je connais tout un tas de gens qui
mangent de la viande tous les jours voir
tous les repas nous notre intérêt c'est
pas que les gens mangent plus de viande
c'est que les gens mangent mieux de la
viande
nous on n'est pas prêt à fournir des
grandes quantités monde est prêt foner
de la qualité donc on arrivera à se
retrouver sur ce terrain là si tous les
consommateurs se décider demain à aller
voir les petits producteurs pour essayer
de se fournir localement de bons
produits il se passerait quelque chose
de très simple c'est que tous les autres
producteurs
et vont s'adapter ils vont s'adapter
parce que aujourd'hui
quoi qu'on veut on est on est pris par
les lois du marché de l'offre et la
demande
on peut difficilement s'en extraire et
si les gens consomment mieux alors les
producteurs produiront mieux
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]